momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por eso nos acompaña en el estudio
nuestra periodista daniela blandón
daniela gracias por acompañarnos hoy se
cumple un mes del break cuál es el
balance ahora andrés buenas noches más
controles retrasos y trámites
burocráticos en la frontera así se
podrían resumir las primeras
consecuencias son los más visibles de la
separación del reino unido- del bloque
económico de los 27 países que tuvo
efecto como recordaremos el pasado
primero de enero los exportadores de
carne británicos dicen que varios envíos
han terminado descompuestos en camiones
a la espera de los controles sanitarios
europeos y los pescadores escoceses
dicen que ya no pueden vender todos sus
peces a europa debido al complejo
papeleo la organización de fabricantes
de make you cake dice que el 60% de la
industria ha interrumpido
significativamente sus actividades desde
el primero de enero el gobierno
británico defiende que el tráfico en el
canal de la mancha es fluido y dice que
los inconvenientes son apenas problemas
iniciales
daniela el nuevo objetivo de la red
social red it son los commodities cómo
es eso el precio de la plata se disparó
hoy hasta un nivel no visto desde 2013 y
muchos analistas lo atribuyen a que el
metal precioso se convirtió en el nuevo
blanco de los pequeños inversionistas
que quieren darle un giro al sistema
financiero mundial
andrés recordemos que la semana pasada
miles de ellos se pusieron de acuerdo en
la red social redes para comprar
masivamente acciones de la empresa
gamestop el precio se disparó y les hizo
perder miles de millones de dólares a
los llamados hedge funds que son de los
más arriesgados de wall street y le
apostaban a que esa acción bajara ahora
lo hacen con la plata escuchamos
y los llamados hedge funds se ganaron un
gran oponente se podría decir que la
aplicación robin hood se volvió
demasiado poderosas espero que si se
llega al extremo los reguladores en eeuu
interfieran pero si llega a lo peor todo
el sistema financiero está en peligro y
ningún político quiere correr ese riesgo
es que yo sí le tengo un dato curioso
andrés el diario de twain que es
especializado en temas de hollywood
anunció que netflix ya estaría
preparando una película sobre este
impresionante fenómeno en parques y
daniela y el gobierno de méxico envió al
congreso la polémica iniciativa de
reforma a la ley eléctrica lo hizo a
través de una iniciativa preferente que
quiere decir que debe discutirse en los
próximos 30 días y de lo que se trata es
de limitar la generación privada de
energías renovables eso para priorizar
la empresa eléctrica del estado en
efecto la reforma modificaría la
prioridad de los agentes a la hora de
generar electricidad primero deberá ir
la energía producida por las
hidroeléctricas y las plantas de
combustibles fósiles estatal
luego las plantas privadas eólicas y
solares y finalmente las de ciclo
combinado esta iniciativa ha sido muy
polémica para el gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador e incluso eeuu se
ha opuesto porque restringe la inversión
extranjera y la generación de energías
dichas daniela y usted nos trae una
noticia bastante curiosa y es que
emiratos árabes creó los tribunales del
espacio para dirimir disputas
comerciales extraterrestres cómo es eso
así como lo está escuchando andrés desde
2014 existen los tribunales del
financiero internacional de dubai y su
tarea desde el milmillonario de litigios
comerciales pero ninguno de ellos hasta
ahora trataba asuntos relacionados con
actividades espaciales pues este nuevo
tribunal que van a crear está diseñado
para que una empresa o país que se
incursionando en esas actividades pueda
por ejemplo tramitar pleitos que puedan
surgir teniendo en cuenta que las
misiones por fuera de la tierra están
aumentando drásticamente y esto se da
cuando emiratos árabes unidos- justo
espera que llegue la amarte una sonda
enviada por ese país era el momento de
conocer los indicadores wall street
recuperó la senda alcista tras una
semana pasada muy volátil en torno a
gamestop eso animó también a las bolsas
europeas así como también lo hizo el
alza en el precio de la plata también
fue un buen día para las bolsas
latinoamericanas en especial en brasil y
nos trae la cifra del día también 7.5
por ciento en esa tasa terminó el
desempleo de la unión europea en 2020
esta es mayor al 65 por ciento del año
anterior y en cifras exactas que quiere
decir 16 millones de personas en los 27
países estaban sin trabajo el cierre de
2020 cerca de 2 millones más que un año
atrás pues daniela muchas gracias por
traernos la información económica aquí
en france 24 y ustedes muchas gracias
por acompañarnos quédense con nosotros
[Música]